hey everyone thank you for joining
uh today i would like to talk about
programming web applications with
f-sharp
and basically retargeting them to kind
of move away from javascript into web
assembly
i'm going to be using uh two
technologies one
web sharper and the other bolero to
present some of these ideas
and hopefully you can learn something
from this
we had certainly been working a lot
quite heavily with web sharper
to develop web applications and in
recent years
uh there had been this steady move a lot
of quest customers have been asking
about
how could they better utilize
webassembly
for example for some of their more
computationally intensive
tasks that they have surfaced onto
thin web clients
so this probably affects a lot of people
uh the technologies to enable that had
been around for quite some time
so i'm just gonna uh dip our toes into
this whole ecosystem uh in this talk
there's just so much just enormous
amount of uh projects huge amounts of
information about
this topic other language communities
uh
most notably rust
had been extremely active in the area
and i think they have a lot of
inspiration to give to us
uh developers coming from other
ecosystems
so
uh with that let me uh jump into web
sharper we only have a limited time here
so i'm going to be quite quick
and
trying to
basically uh
maximize our time
i think the easiest way to get started
would be the cli the net cli you can
install
uh so here i'm showing the commands to
actually install ball arrow and also web
sharper so you can do dot net new and
then dash i and basically either bolaro
dot templates or web sharper.templates
this will put
the project templates onto your system
clearly you will need the net sdk
just even to use the dotnet command and
also to have all the build tools and
everything available so once you have
that uh you can of course create new
projects
uh in the bolaro templates there is a
minimalist approach so it's bola dash
app
code name or pseudoname
the name of the template uh can be
configured using different uh switches
on the command line uh you can opt into
just generating a client-side code that
will be run on webassembly or you can
have a server client
application
so you can configure that you can read
more in the documentation page that i'm
going to show you
in a few minutes
on the web shopper sites
or side things are a bit different we
have different project templates for
different scenarios that you might
actually run into for example if you're
needing a
single page application
then you can do
net new web shopper dash spa
still gave some switches on the command
line that like the name of the project
uh if you prefer you can actually use c
sharp in addition to f sharp so these
templates uh are bilingual so you can
have uh support for c sharp as well or
if you want an html application or a
full client server application you can
use web shopper dash web
there are other templates i'm not going
to
talk about these today there's a nice
documentation page that describes them
we are about to release web shopper six
uh probably early next week and there
will be a new documentation site with a
lot of extra information that we didn't
have before
so once you created a project you can
edit your projects you can run them
using just.net run or you can use uh net
build to build to see for compilation
errors you can toggle the verbosity of
the compiler output
it's it's all basic
dot sdk stuff
so two websites to watch out for is uh
fsboolero.io and webshopper.com
uh i urge you to uh have a quick read
just to see if you are into these uh
technologies i think they're quite fun
so
to help you
get convinced about web shopper
there's this site tri-web shop where you
can go online
the link is on the bottom
and you can uh basically
try out snippets of web shopper code
without actually installing anything or
preparing anything on your system
uh this is actually quite nice
uh you can uh
we will be looking at some of the
examples so don't worry
you can also create your own you can uh
reference
dozens and dozens of different
javascript libraries that we call
bindings or extensions into your
snippets and then you can do charting
like what we see here you can do games
you can do all kinds of other stuff
by default most of the samples will be
reactive
so ui web shopper dot ui as a reference
will be uh given
um and
i think it's quite fun to actually get
started looking at some of these
snippets and seeing what people have
invented i think it's quite fun
all right so let's uh just jump this is
without any coding so i'm not gonna
for this part at least not gonna
demonstrate anything code but if i was
uh to actually put this into a project i
would probably create
uh a simple
like a minimal web shop replication
there's a template for that of course
and just paste this very code that we
see here
and run it so in about a minute we could
get this to run
and uh it would say hello world now the
interesting thing to note here is that
if you look at the main
function or binding here you can see
that we are using application.single
page so this actually will give us a
single page
html application and the content of that
will be a simple h1 tag as we see hello
world now
you can imagine you could write
all kinds of html combinators here
to create markup we actually recommend
that you use html templates external
files so you can make changes to those
uh we will be seeing that here in a
second but i wanted to just basically
reinforce this fact that
we had found through working on number
uh probably dozens and dozens of
different web applications that the
developer workflow goes very much like
this
you want to see
kind of in an abstract way what the
application will look like so you
typically want to have some kind of an
html mock-up a wireframe or even maybe
concrete html designs for the
application at hand that you want to
code
now of course all of that will be pretty
much lifeless
there won't be any kind of interactivity
because the application hasn't been
written yet
but then you start taking that and
treating that as a template and marking
certain areas of the template
maybe you define enough templates
within those templates you actually
define placeholders where things will be
uh served and injected
and then you start writing the
application logic
so
this requires
millions or thousands or hundreds of
recompilation steps so we had realized
this early on that
it would be very beneficial to be able
to load
changes to the markup without actually
requiring recompilation of the
application
and this is what basically uh html
templating via type providers
gets us in a couple slides down the road
i will have a couple examples so just
keep in mind that instead of like what
we do here in lining the h1
or uh or writing in code uh html
combinators we actually would recommend
you to use outside external templates
for this presentation layer
a couple more advanced
examples so this is exactly the same
kind of application uh skeleton here we
defined an endpoint type with uh two
discriminated unions and we had
attribute using attributes like the
endpoint attribute here
we could refine what happens with these
endpoints
so we basically here just refine that
they should be accessible at slash which
is the root of the application or slash
weather which would be another endpoint
and then as you can see whether in this
case takes a string argument
so down in the main
we have
application.multipage now which will be
a standard
application client server application so
here what we see is we basically can
just pattern match
on the discriminated union endpoint type
to see what kind of request came in and
all of the work involved in
parsing the request
uh down to converting into this endpoint
type and then matching on it to see what
we should return all of that work is
automated and we don't have to worry
about it now obviously there's a lot of
details
that should be mentioned here about
refining these endpoints what if i want
to have a post a get or
a delete http verb
what if i want to post like a json
object from which i want to extract
certain things what if i have form data
that i want to get the data from uh post
it to some of these endpoints you can do
all of that
and then once you have
in a pattern match the actual f sharp
representation of the end endpoint like
in this case one of the discriminated
union shapes
then you can respond for example if
somebody requested the home page then we
returned the home page which would
probably be some kind of a template
based html response
in case of a weather we get
as an argument
or parameter and then we as you
can see here just
[Music]
you can do on this version so that's a
typo
but in in case of form data for example
we are expecting to pass the name and
age component uh as form data coming
from our
form tags in html or in the third
example we are trying to get a json
representation in one order
which in this case would follow the
structure defined by the type order data
below so it would have an item and a
quantity
now obviously this could be made into a
list and more and composing it into
larger data structures uh you can pretty
much do that without limitation and now
obviously at some point you you're gonna
find that
uh
coding everything into json and posting
to the endpoint is is is the
fastest way to ship large uh amounts of
data or varied data in to service
endpoints
or or uh
yeah service end points
and to produce some kind of an output
you can use the style template that was
just given in the previous page like
here
uh depending on your endpoint returning
json or
files or uh maybe error code if you if
you want to have some kind of
redirection or signal some kind of an
error or the actual html content like
homepage does
here
i should also talk a little bit about uh
reactivity
although in this talk we're going to use
mvu
the model view update pattern
so here reactivity in web shopper is
is supplied by the functionality from
web shopper ui
the library
so in
pretty much any one of my
applications web shopper applications
that i recently worked on basically i
had web shopper of course as a core
dependency and the second core
dependency was web shopper.ui so it's
kind of like a ubiquitous
reference or dependency that i have in
my applications and obviously some
people are different but i'm pretty much
uh
i could almost almost certainly say that
uh web shopper.ui is the primary
means of producing
html and reactive html applications with
web shopper
it's not the only one you can make your
own html
representation if you wanted
and we will actually see with uh bolaro
how you can change the html
representation within the within a
framework
so you could actually execute that
pretty much the same way in web shop or
just supply another html library uh
using just a reference a library
reference and keep using that but a lot
of the convenience code and helper
functions like for cycles for example
are geared towards using web shopper ui
elements or docs as we have here
so anyhow
i think it's time that i show some
actual code running so in the bottom
uh i have some links so i'm gonna try to
uh
open the first one so this should be the
first one to kind of demonstrate to you
how you can do a reactive uh
computation so so the idea here is very
simple i want to type something here
as i can see i'm going to echo something
underneath and what i'm echoing is
what's written in the actual text box
and i map it to uppercase and i
basically convert it back to text view
which view in this case means the actual
snapshot of a reactive variable like var
which here is bound to the input control
so actually i should get capitalized or
upper uppercase
version of what i'm typing into the box
which is exactly what happens
all right so it looks pretty simple
pretty painless
let me see this other one here
so this kind of goes against the idea of
not using inline html but remember this
is a website where we have uh
snippets although there is a markup tab
and i could have actually used
html templating and then just inject it
uh using the type provider that would
have saved me all of this code
but it's it's okay it's a law it's a
small short example anyhow so what this
is doing is there's an input box hello
and then
we are basically mapping what's typed
into that input box two different things
capitalized reversed we've counted words
so you can see that now you're changing
so once i have a hello world
you can see that how things change
and here the mouse coordinates is a view
of course all of these views are
assembled into a table
and they are basically
output here
using this list.map basically we map
each of those uh key value pairs
into uh
just docs uh html snippets and we
concatenate them and put them into a tea
body
and then in the main content we just
basically have the input field and then
we have this output table which is this
guy here
so within that of course we see this
last one the mouse coordinates coming
from this view mouse coordinates view
which here is basically instead of just
mapping the input like all of these
other ones do it's actually mapping a an
external input which
comes from the
mouse so here if i'm on the application
itself
i can always access where my mouse sits
and we basically just get the x and y
coordinates and then we just output them
as a
little string and then we just show that
but you can see it's pretty
pretty fast
uh this there are a couple other
snippets like drawing for example on a
canvas that you can see here on trivap
sharper uh in fact um
uh
yeah
sorry
i want to show that but then i realized
it's there's so many examples and
snippets here that it's difficult
so um
let's switch back to the slide here
if you are more interested if you're if
you want to
kind of understand what's happening
underneath like this how how these
reactive variables and their views and
how they are projected out into reactive
html if you're interested in that
there's a paper
on the uh
awesome web shopper list which is a
community
repo
that we have
linking some of the material on web
shopper so there's a documentation oh no
actually there's a publication section
on that awesome web shopper list which
is also available by the way if you go
to the
main webshop or website
so you can go into um
the main webshop website so we were on
this try online uh section we can also
have blogs forums support documentation
etc
and what i'm talking about is this link
here awesome web shopper
this has
an academic publication site
and
basically you can read
this paper or
any one of the papers really uh talking
about
um
the actual reactive foundation
underneath and some pragmatic applied
topics on top
for example piglets
reactive forms
these are pluggable view models very
interesting things
as you can see they are kind of
i wouldn't say outdated they're
definitely not outdated are still state
of the art
but they have been around for eight ten
years so a lot of this has been out uh
hasn't really been picked up that much
i would hope that uh some of these ideas
will come to more attention and people
will learn about them
all right
so this is what we saw okay now let's
talk about templating
so if you haven't seen web sharper or
maybe just in the broader sense f sharp
before you probably need some
explanation on this type line so type my
template equals and then this
code here this is actually an invocation
of a type provider
so what's happening here is that we take
the web shop.html file
we traverse it based on the type
provider's logic and we are looking for
certain placeholders
and then we create types
which may or may not have other inner
cool entities
uh
like members or properties etc etc
here
my template will become a whole space of
types like a type space
and in it
there there must be
we are not showing the html5 source here
but within it
i can see that there is a main uh
sort of inner template
which also has like title shopping cart
items to buy as placeholders so those
are the places where i can inject
content the title here is a string
placeholder shopping cart is probably a
dom node placeholder where i can
actually inject html
and then the sent order is probably an
event handler probably an on click event
on a button like a send order button
which on the ui makes it possible that
i'm just basically whatever i have
accumulated in my shopping cart i want
to send it
as my final order so it
then
can be sent to the server for processing
so this is pretty much how the
application
from an initial coding standpoint would
look like and remember in the in the
beginning of the talk we said that you
you want to have some kind of a concrete
or abstract or wireframe design so
that's encapsulated in your webshop.html
and then
defining the proper placeholders event
handlers
you can actually put the code for them
in a code very similar to to this
so this is how you would then
externalize everything that has to do
with the presentation layer at this
point if i compile my application and i
go and make changes in the web shop html
file then the application doesn't have
to be recompiled it just automatically
gets all those changes now obviously
this is a behavior that you might want
to alter
so you can actually pass arguments to
the templating type provider
to say hey watch the source files for
changes and only
load if there is a change
or you might actually say i don't want
any changes to propagate i may actually
change the file but i don't want the
application to reload
uh so you can you can kind of gravitate
in between those two
uh typically the the right choice is in
maybe some production environments uh
disable the watch or the monitoring
maybe you want to still have it on it's
up to you
uh
so definitely uh there's some
uh interesting
uh scenarios for you to try this of
course applies to not only server side
but also client-side templating so the
same very code could be applied in a
html page
where you have a
just basically a shopping cart uh
entirely running on the client side
so if you make changes now obviously
when things are down on the client and
executing in somebody's browser it's
difficult to change the source template
uh
because you no longer have access to it
but
if you refresh the page or whatever then
the change could be applied
all right um
so
all of this templating can also
facilitate reactivity so within your
templates here what i have is a
highlight of like these five lines i
don't know if you can actually see them
but here there there is the index
template which is the whole type space
coming from the type provider
inside is a list item template
which has you know basic things like
some placeholders there's an event
handler for clearing and and so on
but what i can i can do here is i can
i can
connect things
uh into the model that i may have uh
serving
this particular page so the data stored
within the page can also be reactive
bound to the template and in this case
task.name for example is an example of
that
so we have a list model
uh
tasks
which is defined above you can see that
this model that's created in line 18.
this is just basically a dictionary or a
list of uh task
values
and uh
you may have one or you may have zero or
you may have a hundred of these tasks
inside that
model and what we're doing here is we're
loading a template which is just
basically the design how things should
be displayed we're applying that to
every one of these items so if my tasks
changes programmatically or from the ui
then things automatically
refresh
now we could spend probably two hours
explaining how the diffing works
so similar flame frameworks uh
like for example react
they have uh different
ways to deal with this problem some of
the uh
ui foundations
have uh representations for uh
uh basically a virtual dom
and then they have uh
changes that are
uh to be applied on top of what we can
see on the screen and then these changes
can be basically handpicked and
identified exactly where they happen and
then the code that updates based on our
change set is actually quite efficient
so we apply the diff
uh between two doms onto the existing
one and then we arrive at the second
version of the the tree so this way we
minimize
the number of operations to sort of sync
ui changes
but everything else that didn't need to
change remains the same now obviously
this is a
this can be a heavy computation and an
expensive computation if your dom which
is the thing that you represent uh
for your document is large
so
most of the cases you know web web
application designers
this guideline not to have too much
scrolling within a page but
you can also imagine situations where
things are just basically not visible
like you may have an spa which has a lot
of functionality on two or three
different pages but only one of the
pages are shown at any given time but
that doesn't mean that your dom doesn't
have the rest of the pages so in reality
it's very easy to run into situations
where you're working with thousands tens
of thousands of dom nodes within your
tree now obviously if you do dom diffing
that can actually slow things down quite
a bit
so web shopper doesn't do dom diffing it
uses
uh sort of like a data flow
algorithm to propagate changes and then
we have reactive
uh
basically
things that allow you to expose
the changes in reactive
state
into
and reflect those changes into html
and
this will be an example of those
ui designs
coming from a template but also having
the ability to be connected into this
reactive framework
all right that's uh that's all i wanted
to say about web shopper so
there are many talks huge amounts of
documentation about web shopper on the
on the internet
now let's switch to bolero which is the
other uh topic of interest so ball arrow
basically runs on blazer we'll talk
about blazer in a second and it gives
you the ability to program these blazer
applications in f-sharp
using the mvu pattern so mvu is the
model view update
and
bolero itself comes with a lot of web
shopper inspired features uh for example
endpoints so
type representing uh endpoints possible
endpoints into your application
then
from this you can imply that
there's this whole topic of routing how
you route uh things uh in between uh the
different sections of your of your
application uh the same kind of html
template and more
for example
uh we saw
inline html and we sort of advised
against using too much of it and instead
just
referring you to use html templates in
bolero the same applies
but in case you want to inline html
there is none alternative proposal for
its syntax this is using compute
computation expressions
uh so it would look something like this
uh the
one of the biggest biggest benefits of
of having an alternative uh syntax for
html and in this case the one using
computation expressions is because of
recent innovations in this drop compiler
the ability to extend uh inlining in
certain situations it turns out that you
can reduce something like this into very
efficient chain of function calls
which then if you execute would be a lot
less work and also a lot less memory
consumption than having an actual data
value representation of the html which
you accumulate
with your html combinators which then
you print into html at the end
somewhere in the pipeline so this
actually this alternate syntax involves
a pretty heavy dose of optimization and
performance benefits in most of the
scenarios now obviously this wouldn't
deal with a scenario where you need to
inspect or introspect uh the content of
the html that you may
have assembled
uh elsewhere and you need to change it
in in certain places so it doesn't have
introspection abilities
because at this point everything is just
a whole chain of function calls
but you very typically don't need that
kind of introspection
and all you need is just being able to
declaratively uh write out what kind of
html you want and here's the structure
etc etc so anyhow you can track the
progress of that so that's pretty much
ready uh to be released and it should
probably be out soon you can see on the
bottom there's a link for the github
issue okay
i'm not going to talk about templates
again because this is exactly the same
capability that we saw earlier with web
sharper
i just want to
this was supposed to be a video
okay here's a video so this is uh
just shows you the power of the uh
templating engine
so here i have a running application and
you can go out and basically change the
underlying template and in this case we
turn a button into a link
just by uh
changing that inner template and saving
it and as soon as we saved it you see on
the right hand side the buttons have
switched to a hyperlink instead
no recompilation took place in the
server side
it's just a simple file system watch
and then sending a notification to the
client to refresh
all of that
is uh
uh
sort of included better is included
in in uh with in in the library when you
use bolero
of course obviously you can disable
this hot loading hot reload
functionality i'll show you in some of
the code snippets coming up where you
can actually do that
okay remoting of course is one of the
fundamental pieces
that you need to do in a uh
web framework or a web library
now obviously uh web shopper
has and also bolaro has
not a number but several or two or three
different approaches to get remoting
expressed
here's one way you can define sort of a
a record for your service type so
basically listing the rpc functions you
want to have
you can
basically uh define this
record type and you can inject it using
the remote member on uh the program
component which represents uh an mvu
based application in bolaro and then
once you have that injected in this case
uh as backend
then you can pass it down onto your
update function and then the update
function using that backend reference
can make the appropriate calls on
different messages as it receives them
there are other ways you can do
dependency injection etc etc you can
basically read that in the documentation
it's not that important which flavor you
decide
now web shopper traditionally for
example have used a third approach where
we just basically go through the f-sharp
code and we mark using the rpc attribute
certain functions that then suddenly
become available for uh
rpc uh calls
and the compiler makes sure that if
you're translating f-sharp code to
javascript which then calls
a function that all of those functions
are either placed on the javascript side
or they better be marked as rpc and sit
on on a server somewhere
so that's all checked and taken care of
by the compiler itself
now routing
here's an example you typically
so you have an endpoint type
for your pages and then in your model in
the state of your application you want
to basically track which page you are on
so here obviously in the model there's a
page component and then also somewhere
in your messages you need to define hey
here's a message that sets a new page
which basically means move to a
different page of the application
and then router.infer in the bottom
takes care of all the work involved
okay we have 10 minutes i'm gonna just
rush through this
i mentioned how you can turn on uh
hot reloading for templates here the
highlighted line the very last one
basically adds a router similarly there
will be program dot and then
use hot reload etc so there's a whole
bunch of capabilities in that uh module
all right
so uh just to briefly compare uh bolaro
versus web chopper
you pretty much on the ui paradigm you
stick with mbu and bolero on web shopper
you have mbu but you have a lot of
different approaches based on the
reactivity framework that we provide but
the full stack aspect that when you have
a bowler application of course we
haven't talked about the different
hosting models for blazer but
on bolero you typically have the client
running as a net uh application
on a webassembly runtime so this is the
uh
blaze or web assembly uh approach but
with web shopper we take the same.net
code we translate to javascript and then
that runs on the client
okay uh
so why would you use blazer uh so this
is uh not a talk on that because this is
just one of the fundamental pieces that
we rely on but basically it allows you
to move away from javascript to net for
your
client-side code which also brings a
large part of the dotnet equal system to
the client
uh because it actually can run in a
webassembly interpreted
net runtime
you may actually have a pretty good
performance compared to javascript but
you definitely have a better reliability
and security guarantees
because of the
webassembly
runtime and just running webassembly in
a contained manner
and also better code sharing of course
you have between your net source
server and client
language parts
so here are the three different blazer
hosting models you can have the web
assembly which i just explained the
server model is a very interesting model
where everything is running on the
server and we just basically sent dom
changes using signalr back to the client
this is computationally and resource uh
usage-wise very heavy as you have more
and more users accessing your website so
this is not something that you should
use on a large scale but this would be
very very perfect for
just small scale testing of your
application before you roll it out
there's a new hybrid approach where you
can build native applications and you
have a web view that basically it's
running on top of blazer you can read
more about these hosting models on the
link below
now here's an mvu uh model view update
application we had already seen how you
communicate using messages and change
and update the model uh that you have
using the update function and then
here's the view typically in blazer or
uh sorry bolero and web shopper
applications you use html templating you
set up certain things and then and then
from some of these dispatch events like
here decrement and increment will be
buttons uh to increment the counter
and value is the thing that you see as
the current value you can see that on a
setter you also dispatch a message
and this would be the source html
template for for for that
view function
and this is what it would look like
uh really what i wanted to discuss is
the uh to do mvc
app this is an application basically
almost
uh 99
the same in web shopper and in bolero
you have a couple things that you can
change uh to go in between the two of
course obviously you need to swap out
the dependencies instead of relying on
web shopper you need to change them to
bolero and then you can take the very
same f sharp code or most of mostly the
same f sharp code and then suddenly
instead of targeting javascript for your
client
using web sharper you now had switched
your application to
targeting
or
running in a web assembly runtime
so uh you can learn about this in the
sample project of course in the github
repo the github link that i uh showed in
the bottom
uh there's one bit of information that i
should highlight here that if you
do use the web shopper mvu
approach so basically stick you stick
with generating javascript
uh you will find that from the
traditional model view update uh the
render function somewhat there uh
[Music]
deviates because it takes not the model
but the view of the model this is a
small and fine detail that i think is
kind of underappreciated at this moment
it basically just means that instead of
having access to the raw model so that
you can change it you can't so this
makes it the model
uh and and and appreciates that the
model is not changeable in the render
function
obviously it's not changeable in in the
mvu because you you're passing the model
as a value
uh
but this is just a subtle distinction
and just a small difference that you
need to be aware of
other than that there is a website for
mvu
i'll just show you that i think
if i can switch over
so these
so here's mvu itself you can learn about
the architecture
uh some of the features like time travel
debugging this is not something that's
up to date so there's a security warning
because the plugin used for uh the time
travel debugging is actually uh getting
outdated and have some warnings you can
uh use local storage html templating
there's a paging mechanism coming with
web shopper mbu
so
here's the routing
and then the differences that i was
talking about
and then some of the applications some
sample repositories that you can learn
from
all right
and just finally uh before we kind of
close
uh
here is a uh mvu somewhat slo slightly
larger example where we use components
in other components so this is like a
scalability
topic here
this actually defines a counter like we
have seen but also puts multiple of
these counters on a single page and you
can see how we compose messages
into each other to sort of have this
subsumption into a
a larger component
all right
i think
there are a couple things that i
just kind of rushed over
and before i close i really should
mention uh blazer
aot which is the
ahead of time compilation so basically
having the same ability that we have
seen
but compiling down not to
uh
dotnet dlls but to web assembly directly
now obviously the output size is going
to be larger
but it's definitely going to be faster
than the interpreted
uh
uh approach with a blazer web assembly
so this is something that we need to pay
a very close attention to i think it has
a lot of potential because this is now
saying that you can take any dot net
language f sharp c sharp what not and
compile it down directly to webassembly
now this also means that you can
interrupt with a huge and growing
webassembly ecosystem coming from
your.net application code base
now obviously
at this point we have to say and point
out that webassembly still lacks access
to certain features like for example to
the dom itself
so we are falling back to using
javascript for these
but only for now so
a lot of people are anxiously waiting
when uh webassembly is able to access
the dom because at that point a lot of
the javascript dependencies can go away
uh and just closing down i really would
like to mention and point out the ros
community and all the work that they
have been doing on webassembly
they have this wonderful
ecosystem
they can compile to webassembly very
efficiently they also have tooling for
example to take javascript libraries and
javascript code in general and provide
bindings uh to those javascript code
pieces by generating stubs that you can
then use in your application that you
compile to webassembly so it's
really a cool approach and i think it's
a wonderful way to build applications
now obviously this is exactly the same
kind of situation that dotnet would
arrive in once we have the aot
compilation
refined producing small that could
eliminated and
optimized code and hopefully we'll get
there or at least get somewhat closer in
net seven
thank you very much for your attention
i'm gonna be hanging out in the lounge
uh to answer any questions you may have
and otherwise have a good day thank you
very much
thank you grant
thank you everyone for hanging around
and listening to granite